this is a production of Cornell
University welcome to the personal
statement workshop my name is Erin
Larson and I'm a fifth year PhD
candidate in ecology and evolutionary
biology and I am cinnamon I'm a fourth
year student yeah and so we'll be
talking a little bit today and I'll talk
about what we'll actually be doing
during the personal statement workshop
but we'll spend about 15 minutes talking
to you guys about personal statements
generally and then we'll break out into
our small groups where we'll talk about
the personal statements that we read for
you guys sorry I'm gonna try and then we
will also have you guys do some peer
editing with each other while you're
trading off talking with your grad
student editors and so to start with I
think a personal statement is one of the
most mysterious black box II parts of a
grad school application it's the part
where you're like what exactly am I
supposed to say here what am I supposed
to do and so we wanted to unpack a
little bit what exactly a personal
statement is I know you guys wrote one
for DPW you probably have written some
if you've been applying for grad schools
this past year but generally a personal
statement is somewhere between two to
four pages long depends on the school
follow the instructions they give you
for length and formatting and things
like that but it's really an opportunity
for you to expand on your CV so all
those sentences that you want to write
about the different jobs you had the
different experiences you had some
things that you didn't get to put on
your CV if you want to explain why you
took some time off before going to
undergrad why you switch schools the
personal statements a great place to
kind of explain your CV it's also a
chance for you to show your voice and
your personality and who you are um and
it's more of a picture of you as both a
person and a researcher um that said
it's not necessarily a place to tell
them everything that you like to do in
your spare time unless it's really
related to how that would help you
succeed in grad school I mean it's also
a way to show that you're resilient that
you have grit that you're gonna have
what it takes to make it through the
long long road that it is that is a PhD
or a master's degree and so in terms of
structure there's sort of a general
structure that we'll talk about here
but it also might depend on the prompts
that you get given by a specific school
that you're applying to sometimes
they'll give you some really specific
directions of what they want to see in a
personal statement but very generally
you obviously want to have an
introduction so you want to have some
sort of narrative hook one example of a
hook might be an anecdote from your
childhood or from and sometime in your
lifetime that about why you decided you
want to study biology but keep that
pretty short and sweet because they're
really what you want to be able to get
into is your recent past in terms of
sort of the post high school your
influential classes your mentors your
research experiences and then into your
future so you want to make sure that
you're also forward-looking as you move
towards the end of that personal
statement so you're talking about why
you want to go to grad school
specifically why you want to go to grad
school at that particular place that
you're applying to and why it's a good
fit for you and then you want to sort of
wrap it all up with some sort of
forward-looking summary statement or
conclusion and so it can be a little
overwhelming to get started you guys
already have done that though you
already have something that you can work
with and edit but you want to make sure
that you know your audience you only
know the department that you're applying
to what are they looking for what a
professor is doing there what's the
school like is it a more agriculturally
focused school is it a school that
focuses more on theoretical biology
something like that and you also want to
know the strengths and resources it has
and why you want to go there and what
about it is drawing you there especially
like we mentioned before if they ask you
specific questions to address you want
to make sure that you hit those in your
personal statement and then you also
want to think about what have been your
influential experiences what's driving
you to want to study biology and to want
to go to graduate school and you can
really shape your outline around those
and then you'll finally craft a clear
main message with supporting information
which is just as easy as it sounds but
and what we'll talk about too a little
bit is how to actually kick it up a
notch so how to make sure that your
personal statement really shines one
thing to do is to make sure that you
tailor each of your personal statements
to each school so you can have sort of
your modular personal statement that
you've crafted but then make sure that
your
and you're liking it into school that
you're applying to and that means
thinking about specifically naming
professors possibly that you're excited
about working with our specific
resources at each of those schools and
you also want to make sure that this
piece of this document is in
conversation with your research
statement too so that doesn't mean that
they totally overlap but you can mention
some of the same experiences that you
mentioned in your research statement but
maybe go more into depth about how they
developed you as a person and as a
researcher rather than specifically the
research that you did um also make sure
that you get feedback on this this is
gonna be an opportunity for you guys to
get lots of feedback and but send it to
friends family professors mentors the
more feedback and more drafts you can go
through the better and cinnamon we'll
talk a little bit about how helpful that
feedback can be I'm really light you
shine through and don't be afraid to
have some of your voice your personal
experiences that you feel comfortable
sharing and really be the hero of your
own story it can be a little hard to
want to toot your own horn but this is
the place to really be the active
participant in your narrative and make
sure that you give yourself lots of time
to actually go through all these drafts
and editing so even though this seems
like maybe the thing that you want to do
last when you're doing your applications
for grad school make sure you leave
yourself plenty of time to actually
focus on this but you guys are in great
shape for
so now cinnamon is going to take us
through a motivating real-life example
of a personal statement
so what I'm going to show you is
actually two versions of personal
statement and for the GRS P and which is
a graduate research fellowship program
and so the first version was not
successful I did not get the fellowship
the second version was and I think the
thing that changed the most in my
application packet was actually my
personal statement and so I'm going to
take us through what I change between
the first and second time that I applied
okay and so just first some overall tips
and so I'm going to tell you these tips
and then give you some concrete examples
so something that's really important is
to be space conscious and then also you
don't have to try to fit in every life
experience it is a personal statement
but they don't need to know every step
of your whole life
it's okay to editorialize I'm also
avoiding vague freezing which I'll get
more into you avoiding cliches showing
and not telling so it's one thing to say
oh I love biology it's another thing to
show that you love biology and then last
as erin was saying it's really really
important to get help editing and so
this difference between the first and
second versions wasn't just like me like
sitting in my office like thinking about
how I can make it better a lot of it
with suggestions that I got from mentors
and other students that we're applying
for this grant okay
and so this is the overall intro and so
you can see in draft one it's pretty
long and the second one I actually ended
up deleting an entire paragraph and and
so the first thing I deleted and so it's
really tempting to start with a summary
of what you're going to talk about in
your essay but most of these are pretty
short two or three pages so you don't
need a summary upfront and it can be
helpful to start with the summary just
to orient yourself but you don't need to
have this and the second thing that I
cut a lot out of was tracking my exact
story through college so I started off
in a different major and then I was like
oh I want to study cancer and now I
don't I'm gonna study plants and I'm
gonna say frogs and if that doesn't all
need to go in here
so you can just so this is everything I
did I changed this to one sentence so
it's okay to like have a winding path
that you don't need to recapitulate it
here and something else that I did a lot
definitely when I first started writing
and that I've seen in some of the essays
that I was looking through um is like
this really big in cliche opening
sentence and this is actually taken like
from my from my actual essay so a lot of
people will have some version of Oh from
an early age I was like trumping in the
puns or like interested in nature like
you know whatever but like everyone will
say this so don't so don't see that so
and then this like second example so
these are all sentences from the first
version um so that's like early
engagement in nature which sounds really
great but it's like what does that even
mean I don't know like what was I doing
and then the last one is this
fascination which led me to study the
biology also this fascination pretty big
okay and so this is probably like the
biggest change that I made in my
personal statement so Aaron mentioned a
little bit the narrative hook and this
is where you're really doing the showing
and not telling and this idea actually
wasn't my idea somebody else who had
gotten the GFP read my drafting was like
oh yeah this is nice but like your first
draft is really big and could you give
some sort of like anecdote um so you can
see this first draft and be up in a
rural setting blah blah blah
lots of people have that and then I
changed it into like more this story
which I could read to you or I can give
you a second to read okay so I did this
dramatic okay and all right so here's my
final intro to my dear a few thousand
nine pm I'm lying on my stomach it's six
inches of stinky gooey pine muck and
peering down a dark drainage pipe the
hunched forms of Ranikhet Vienna the
American bullfrog visible but beyond my
reach a foot to your left I call to my
field he was attempting to startle the
frogs down the pipe of the pole she
Pat's one of the frogs and it hops into
my range hammering I lunged to sweep it
into my net I got it
I stand triumphant grinning ear-to-ear
mission accomplished this is not a story
from my most recent field season this is
me at nine years old although not much
has changed in the field assistant is my
younger sister the mission to catch the
Frog for Show and Tell and so so this is
one example it's obviously an example
from my childhood but I've also seen
this done successfully with other types
of stories it could be a classic you
tick it could be a question that you
think about a lot and I saw one really
good example of I was going through and
some of your statements somebody is
really interested in like invasive
species and so the process of like
realizing that organisms that they
really loved as a kid are actually like
invasive organisms and so it doesn't
have to be exact and and then another
nice thing to do is if you start with
some sort of example to kind of weave it
through as you go on and so I showed you
earlier this sort of big like Oh early
exposure like fascination whatever but
then I linked it back to these actual
concrete things that I would then go on
to talk about in my research statement
and so mutability watching the drain
pipe fill with water and then drain
which is when you can see the frogs
interconnectedness and diversity with
all the animals of the pond and so if
you're gonna go this route it's really
nice to tie it into actual concrete
ideas and things that you want to study
in grad school
okay and then the last thing which we
are like really hammering home today is
it is so important to have somebody else
read your statement and so you can see
these are three different people that I
had read my statement between the first
and second time and there's a lot of
read a lot of deleted things and added
things and that this is super important
and like don't be afraid of it it is a
personal statement so it can feel kind
of uncomfortable but it's so important
and something else
oh yeah it's also different from a
college statement and which I was
talking about the beginning and it's you
really have to make sure it goes back to
ultimately what you're interested in
pursuing in graduate school and which
was that Aaron was saying and then a
last point and that I think has come up
a lot um is how to talk about difficult
situations and so a lot of people will
have something that came up for them
personally or academically that affected
grades and so it's okay to talk about
those things in your personal statement
it's a good opportunity to explain any
sort of like adversity that you faced
and a couple of pointers on that and
it's good to be brief if you can you
don't want to go into the situation so
much that you're cutting out a
discussion of your research interests
for example and it's also good for the
purpose of a personal statement to be
generally positive and forward-looking
and so okay that's it then I think we're
gonna take we'll take questions too so
you guys are gonna have I'm sorry you
can cut press we're gonna and have a
little bit of a brief Q&A for you guys
but also keep in mind that you're gonna
be meeting one-on-one with two grad
students who also read your personal
statement so if you have a question that
you feel like is like a general one from
this that might be helpful for a lot of
you guys to hear about um that was a
time to do that and then we'll break out
into those smaller groups
right so the question was this idea of
like if you get conflicting information
about like oh this anecdote it's great
versus like oh this anecdote sucks and
the idea too that like the people that
you're applying to might have differing
opinions um so one way that I would
think about getting around that is
really do your research on the school
and the resources I think um cinnamons
example is awesome of her narrative hook
but that's not like the only way to do a
narrative hook either there's a lot of
different ways to open up in a way that
kind of draws the reader and it has your
voice and it should be something that
feels natural to you and your story so
if writing about catching frogs with
your sister and that way it doesn't feel
like something that would be very
genuine to you then you know it's not
like a prescriptive you have to start
your statement this way does that make
sense yeah well I think that gets to the
idea too of like the explaining
difficult situations but making sure
that you keep it brief and that you keep
it towards the future the idea of the
personal statement is that you're
spending a little bit of time looking
backwards and reflecting but you're
using that to drive here's what I'm
doing next like this is what's
motivating me to move forward and to go
to grad school in to succeed in grad
school not so much just like I'm looking
back like it's not a therapy session you
know I'd be like like you're kind of
trying to take away the main lessons
that you learned from each thing in a
way that's looking forward which can be
a really tough balance to strike yeah
and this yeah like this explaining
situations like I had something that
like affected my grades and my first
draft actually like there's a paragraph
on it and then I had someone that was
like yeah yeah like what Aaron's saying
like being positive and forward-looking
and then also getting other people to
look at it to see you like Oh
this like strike you and I okay way am I
like presenting it is like oh this is
something that shows that I am like
really resilient and like really like
dedicated to this path there is this
something that is like taking away from
the rest of my or like drawing attention
away from the rest of my application so
getting feedback on that is also yeah
Oh something let's repeat the question
yeah so the question was this was for my
GFP and then asking if he had included
grades for this I think they did
included there's a transcript yeah yeah
so this gets back to it Aaron was saying
about reading the instructions so
there's actually it went back and looked
at my actual grad school apps in there
and there's a lot of variation and what
different universities will ask for some
of them do like a combined personal so
the GRP does a combined personal
statement with research experience so
those are both together other
universities will have like a statement
of purpose separate from a research
statement and then some just have one
statement so you really have to read the
directions for the specific University
yeah I so I'm teaching freshman writing
right now and I cannot express enough is
like if I swear for the maybe not the
crappy first draft is very important so
it's so much easier to start with a
crappy or maybe not so crappy but maybe
not quite right for this particular
thing um piece of writing and then edit
it to fit the next thing than it is to
be like blink page ah to write like five
pages about this thing so yeah what you
guys and what we've seen and editing and
what you guys applied with for your
personal statement is like a place to
start or grad school applications in
some cases I know some of you folks have
already applied with the personal
statement that you said those two so
like it's better to start with something
and then you can kind of move paragraphs
around and expand more on one point if
you need to lengthen add in a new idea
like but it's better to start
with something to edit that should start
with a blank page in a lot of pieces
yeah yeah that's a great point and so
the idea of having your letter writers
go into some of the more detail about an
adverse experience you had or a couple
of semesters or however whatever came up
is to keep in mind too that you have
this whole thing as a whole package and
the personal statement is one point of
that package so it's okay for some
things to be brief in some places and to
be expanded on in other places as well
yeah it's also good practice to send
these statements to your letter writers
um we can take one more question then I
think we're gonna need to time just
timewise move out into the editing so
you get time with your grad student and
peer advisors if there's our editors I
mean if there's any other questions or
lingering things
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu